Disney has canceled a plan to build a
nearly 900 Million Dollar corporate
campus in Florida it's also shutting
down a costly new hotel nearby amid a
high profile dispute with the governor
the days of putting one company on a
pedestal with no accountability are over
in the State of Florida Jacob Passey has
been covering this story for the journal
and explains why Disney is reversing
course on two of its major Investments
Disney was planning to create an office
campus in Lake Nona Florida located in
Orlando roughly 20 miles from the Walt
Disney World Resort the campus was going
to house roughly 2 000 employees most of
whom were being relocated from Southern
California and the campus was going to
be about 2 million square feet so
multiple buildings and it was a really
huge development both for Disney and for
Florida
additionally Star Wars Galactic star
Cruiser is going to be shutting down at
the end of September dubbed by fans the
Star Wars Hotel this was a multi-day
multi-night experience where you got to
live out your own Star Wars Adventure it
was first announced back in 2017 and
opened just last March and cost around
350 million dollars to build according
to sources the journal spoke to the
galactic star Cruiser experience came up
against multiple headwinds for starters
it was very expensive to operate unlike
a normal Hotel it had way more employees
folks in costumes and you know
characters roaming at all times it was
only about a hundred rooms though so
Disney had tight margins on this project
Disney cited changing Economic and
Business conditions as their reasoning
behind shutting down these two projects
more recently Disney has announced that
they're going to be cutting around 7 000
jobs across the company and shedding
around 5.5 billion dollars in expenses
Disney is also in the midst of a war of
words and a legal battle with Governor
Ron DeSantis of Florida this conflict
started last year when Disney spoke out
against the so-called don't say gay bill
that Governor Ron DeSantis championed
my job is not to kowtow to some woke
Corporation in Burbank California my job
is to stand up for the children of my
state since then he has championed a
number of legislative moves aimed at the
Reedy Creek development which used to
control the land where Walt Disney World
Resort is located he shifted that and
put in his own political appointees into
a new board that oversees that
development the corporate Kingdom
finally came to an end
in response to the changes of the Reedy
Creek District Disney has filed a
federal lawsuit claiming that DeSantis
and other Florida lawmakers are
retaliating against the company for
exercising its first amendment rights I
don't think the suit has Merit I think
it's political these projects were going
to bring some high-paying jobs to
Central Florida employees there we're
going to be earning on average 120 000 a
year so you can imagine the impact to
local tax revenues and local businesses
that were going to benefit from those
workers being relocated to Florida
Disney CEO Robert Iger had previously
committed to investing 17 billion
dollars in Florida over the next decade
bringing thousands of jobs to the state
but right now given these changes it
remains to be seen whether that actually
happens
foreign